soothing music gets more terrifying
every time we play hey I have the
resonable 20th anniversary theme on my
playstation 4 so it's the original save
music nice every time there's a red glow
in my room every time I turn it on I
feel like other people might be creeped
out but it soothes me yeah the resin
evils save room area is actually like
really nice like it is something you'd
probably go to sleep to but it's also
like eerie I don't know it's coming it's
relaxing what's also uncomfortable I
don't know you can see this that well in
the camera
there's my resonable 7 oh that's nice
gift from Tim Terry over at Capcom no
collusion involved it's I didn't cover
reso 7 outside of a in-depth documentary
all right let's go
cool let's go to it so I wanted to talk
to you about my cousin Mary if you're
new bringing we play all the Resident
Evil's we're on Veronica go I thinking
about bringing this the first aid spray
because I need it
yeah cuz I've been doing a real [ __ ] job
do you think I need all this other stuff
like this no hazard cars last thing you
got I think I want that yeah you do
I honestly don't know about the
duralumin case so you need a lockpick to
open it right I got this case but I
don't have a lock picks I'm gonna leave
that I'm not doing great
Boggan arrows last time I do have bow
gun arrows but I have no bogans
you might soon though why would I need a
rack I do not have any gun let alone
guns that would mean a rack waiver no
it's a joke
it's from a movie one movie um mean you
have very different taste in cinema
that's not true I only like the highest
quality I'm not saying I like high
quality movies sweet
it's the excellent people you know Oh
like buildings have Bill & Ted's
Excellent Adventure
no not Bill and Ted the other one Wayne
and Wayne's World Wayne's World um he's
like his girlfriend gets him a gun rack
for his birthday he's like I do not have
a gun okay anyway I'm leaving okay I
didn't go well take my phone away I'm
getting slacks work-related slacks that
I don't want sorry are you begging the
palace
you got the biohazard cart Oh wheat so
we kind of teased this to the end of the
last episode there's a worm and
mini-boss coming up I [ __ ] forgot
about the worm me too
alright so I'm probably gonna die well
member I was telling you don't have to
fight it
oh right cuz it's like I took an open
area what do you do around it do you
remember if it's to the left of the
right I know
oh yeah it was that I believe it's this
way cuz it was next it was that little
door next to the gate that you didn't
see not gate like big garage
yeah yeah that's the right so you didn't
see that door in us yeah it looks the
same this is like shoddy craftsmanship
Dreamcast graphics well ps2 it what am i
doing I don't know just right now we
just started you didn't make much
progress so I'm gonna see how you react
run [ __ ] yeah didn't go well good thing
you just started hey I know it's more
than a worm that was like a gaping worm
ma what do you do with that lake I think
you just gotta go to the right door
that's just unlucky and you also were on
super low health right
I was not doing great yeah
I'm on like caution I just stay on a
caution not get even I got egg I got it
this time
take - [ __ ] it's not a great start I
don't like this beer that much sorry no
no I'm not blaming you I'm just saying
I've had it before and I always tell
myself I'm gonna like it but I don't I
Brown here likes it the bunt a Morel
yeah I get lots of like I like this goes
I've been drinking this blood orange
goes I think it's good well your
birthday thing was last weekend oh yeah
my bday thanks for coming well I
actually can evil published during it
yeah I think that's why I didn't retweet
it I was like in the zone and also like
little you know toasted probably mm-hmm
all right so was there a closer door
yeah kind of like a cross directly
across from the camera okay it's not in
that worm stomach is it this oh it
didn't grab you this time
I'm fine run right oh it got you on the
comedown try one more time and then
maybe you should heal before that no it
was literally like as you cross that
corridor it's straight across okay sorry
this is the one
this reminds me of resident evil 3
nemesis I would just that game was
morally draining Simoni morale draining
do morally as well I felt like I win him
a worst person I was not okay by the end
of it like I was so defeated as like a
person and as a gamer I felt like I was
[ __ ] at video games when I was done
which it can be but like they just made
me feel so bad about myself
oh yeah but I think personally from my
standpoint I think resi will - yeah and
then for were my favorites to watch for
was funny just because I think for you
were more acclimated controls so funny
[ __ ] happen anyway like shooting the
chickens and banging on the elevator
I have clutch moments to come not always
trash but most of the time I'm trash if
we have bigger room here we could bring
on like guests every once in a while
maybe not for like maybe in the future
you just interview people while they die
- worms alright here we go yeah this one
yeah I think so yeah alright idiot
stupid dumb worm
oh mama that's a I want that okay I got
two full heels here come in coming cuz
I'm on caution should I wait until I get
hit one more time I can do that there's
a lot going on here let me let me check
the I did the wrong button let's check
the map eat happy mappy so that's the
worm area in the blue right is wait it
must be right a card reader silver in
color oh wait can you use the biohazard
card on that or I don't know
up the stairs are over here and let's
check over here
let's check this somebody knocked over
this ashtray
there's this door please don't be a
zombie please don't be a zombie please
don't be a zombie
[ __ ] where are they
god I love that at first I didn't like
it but now I'm like all in I was like in
a world war one uniform what is that one
horrible be lately what about it I don't
know ahora book I was reading um so a
few people who watch Knievel might know
but you and I used to do at the dead air
pocket oh yeah that was really fun when
you were here still it was about horror
games and movies horror in general and
also how can evil spawn is it this thing
find out oh there's a herb all right I
mean I can really fold anything
actually I'm also gonna do [ __ ] all
right
that's some [ __ ] oh my god yes shoot him
please no it's the terror the new show
they just started on AMC based on the
2007 book from Dan Simmons about the
house the name of that expedition
the terror in the Arabic what well you
oh there you go
two British Royal Navy ships that went
to force the Northwest Passage before
the Panama Canal was built in 1845 I
believe 1846 something like that the
spring and fall of a summer of 1845
until like 1848 but they vanished uh-huh
then they found the evidence of them I'm
not hearing turns out that they're like
some [ __ ] happened to the crews but it's
not completely known so in 2007 Dan
Simmons published a fictional historical
fiction novel with like a horror aspect
of this thing chasing them across the
Arctic it's very scary it's a very good
book but the show started and these guys
look like they were dressed in World War
1 uniforms and then that reminded that
Dan Simmons also wrote a book where
there was a ghost that dress and wore
one uniform and that reminded me the
terror which is start the other night my
first two episodes are goodness this
long explanation all right so there's
like three things in here that are
secured with a simple lock that's what
it says simple ah yeah I blacked out and
just start talking for I know no but
actually in all seriousness it's kind of
because it's a horror show you should
watch the terror on AMC if you get the
chance you can binge it if you have like
AMC prime or something but otherwise
just on AMC every Monday night okay I
printed out a map without any help it
was good last year you know what you
know it was amazing I haven't seen it
yeah I like it a lot it was too long in
my opinion they could have cut like 20
minutes off half an hour off how long
was it total two hours before tea
minutes like okay I'm gonna say this
right now I've never ever in my life
seen an example of a movie that was over
two and a half hours where I was like
yet needed to be that long never there's
no excuse
you probably did you like the extended
editions allure the Rings or is that a
weird case where they're like bonus
version those are bonus that's like your
own problem what I'm saying is that I
went to theatres cut to like two hours
balls oh so you haven't seen Shoah
whatever it was that nine hour movie
about the Holocaust
it's literally nine hours know I could
be getting there and show up no I don't
know what you watch we just established
that our cinematic tastes are different
yeah you watch Shoah no I haven't seen
it I just know it's nine hours sounds
like you're really into show of revenant
you probably didn't like revenue I
[ __ ] I hate this game did you like
revenant yes this [ __ ] like this doesn't
work yeah you got time they're really
perfect yeah like I'm [ __ ] I bet you
among caution pisses me off
why define good did you like revenue
really I'm just trying to pick out two
and a half hour plus movies I mean I
feel like it could have been shorter
yeah
my statement remains that there's
nothing where I'm like I so glad this
movie was that long oh okay what can I
like find out if there's somebody past
there or no okay there's two no they're
coming
they look like Nazis oh you went hi oh
nice
okay nice those lockers again anyway how
do you get up like that you see that I
did oh [ __ ]
that's not what I meant I need the guns
also how do you come back to life
get on the ground
that's not ammo on top of that cigarette
machine or gumball machine I think
that's a magazine I was at a nudie mag
actually I think yes sir I did
like turn your head left it's like
someone's sitting with their legs out it
could be I feel like in my mind's in the
gutter like you kind of have to enhance
[ __ ] so many of these things
wait did you pick up that last side no I
did not you should cuz I I'm just
running out of slots here yeah I wonder
what the maximum is in each slot cuz now
you have 30 element 16 oh there's
another open Locker
yes can this room it looks like there's
a lot okay
I mean I just bring that weird like I
don't like thank you but like I don't
even have a gun yet yeah you check this
one all right I checked that one that
one had arrows in it so glad about that
everything else going on back near that
dead dude you know he just he was kind
of hoping he'd have like a key card or
check that vent okay there's a weird at
the door oh okay that's all right
maybe I can like throw these arrows at
people what is that a spa [ __ ]
you like you started to worry but you
didn't finish it we're gonna say
spaghetti me [ __ ] that guy looks
terrible let's see if we can iPhone hi
son
nice got it flawless yes nope well
oh he's crawling that's a bad move dick
get out the way
goddamn that's my like first successful
knife killing oh really
in or out
okay there's a lot of hot air I say that
about Mike sometimes the hot air will be
coming out of me in a second II mean
you're like Bart yeah it's a threat you
they're like all their skins all gross
cuz they've been like wet gross all
right I guess I'm gonna go down there
and knife this do sure here we go looks
like a stall
I should notice these zombie things that
you can freeze with a song of can I get
down son songs alright I guess I know
it's oh I do swim I'm uncomfortable
redead that was way off I haven't shaved
in a while and it gives me a little
anxiety
who is that a bucket what is that you
see that see it under the stairs oh yeah
hey can I ring you got a lightning scar
do you no I don't like Crouch can i
crowd you can shrink hey can I crash no
what is this Rick Moranis is next video
making me nervous at all number the
sharks and resin will remake yes
[Music]
thank you
I was playing Far Cry 5 there's a
section where you turn quite a lot of
valves to open doors it's very annoying
interesting she read a label on that
okay see what's for storage should I do
something with this I don't think I can
do you like military cards ok cool well
I guess I'll just try to use this key in
some storage let's see what happens
how's that sound that's not good
everybody mm-hmm anything else going on
in here that I should know about doesn't
seem like any he'd killed everything Oh
as it should be man I haven't thought
about redeads in a while and played
ocarina of time and explained early
ocarina yeah that was the game I played
most in my life I think
my favorite is Majoris though I know I
like keep quitting majora I hate having
to do things at certain times I think
it's like a brilliant game but it's also
not the best game it's there's a lot of
flaws but I love it for him
I haven't tested this yet oh sweet do I
still have the card okay idea
so I'm full here oh Lord oh I don't like
this I don't like nothing
no heaven I do I [ __ ] just saved like
a I'm not ready no you didn't just
I didn't just save you'll be alright
is it worm related I don't have any no
okay no this is a cutscene oh it's the
[ __ ] dude in the palace that was
shooting at you
alfrid oh this is a boss fight isn't it
he's run yeah
idiot alright what should I do check out
the stairs
can you go anywhere else all there's
fire it looks like you had a good thing
he would good thing you let you go up
the stairs oh what a little a little
Butthead you know assuming he locked it
behind them uh why like is my heart
pounding I like yeah this camera angle
sucks too why it's so stressful away in
my back
where am i Who am I where am I
have you seen that no about the back
Child's Gambino is still donald glover
college
you do I'm killing it
[Music]
please be a safety area with hockey
pucks please yeah oh wait I can't
[ __ ] pick them up unless there's a
yeah I should probably save right hockey
pucks
like I said 60% certain the best storage
key yours you can use that back of where
you came from
just one okay good three so I for for
savers I know I can't pick anything else
up I got to put all this [ __ ] away you
don't need that right now actually I'll
get rid of spray cuz you might find it
right over here okay
it's probably enough right that good
yeah I could put these away and then
yeah just use them up okay okay what's
that
it's very lucrative I don't know what
hemostatic is that me hemostatic would
just mean like we are these more arrows
would still I don't know it's a green
I'll just put all these things away for
now and then we can decide later what we
want to do
oops I'll just come back for it
cuz I don't want to live like this
anymore
I think I was playing something
elsewhere
oh sorry hemostatic was the [ __ ] that
the dude at the very beginning needed
remember that dude that let you out of
your jail cell yes
so bring that back to him at some point
oh right
you think he's still alive he was
annoying it's been a while all right
should I say ever what yeah okay so I'm
gonna take one way and one puck and I'm
gonna save right now and then we'll
continue you can save your progress with
us
I love typewriters used to have one my
parents didn't like my stepdad had a
typewriter I thought it was really cool
to like play with but like I didn't
really ever use one for writing I just
thought they were neat
I love in Mad Men how the office instead
of keyboard noises Philip typewriter
noise yeah they did a good job of like
kind of putting you in the world in
there so I'm gonna take these things and
then move on what do you think's that
okay son good yeah right away why did
that helmet look interactable on the
ground
alright I'll go back did you try the
door that alfred went through was it
locked after he shot at you I didn't
actually know what door he went in okay
nevermind nothing that's right
doesn't that helmet look like you it
does yeah I didn't know what Shore he
went in to be honest with you I like
picked one at random so I can try both
okay I'll try that one
after I try this one I'm glad I saved
I'm so glad I saved
[Music]
[Music]
sounds like a spongebob character okay
cool
perfect hey Luna mansion and resident
Eve so still going through here I guess
yes yeah only way you can go all right
well I'm really glad I saved
alright let's move along alright
very dramatic what is that cracking the
floor Oh like that guns that I have guns
what do I do with my guns I should use
my guns first right do you think I'll be
able to come back hopefully I just
really hope so from what I remember
those are like much better versions of
these guns
well [ __ ] but what's your inventory look
like right now all right I can take them
to me take them yeah but then I can't
take anything else ok I can take them
and then I I could take them and then
throw away these shitty machine guns if
I have to mmm what do you mean you do I
don't know so there's an item over there
to Greener
can I leave alright how about this
there's a key that I took that I don't
think I need I'll just put that away
I could also not take my knife leave the
key take the knife leave the key take
the cannoli
there's a lot of planning going into
this and I'll probably just die but I
think it's worth it just to see what's
going on here there that gives me like
one extra slot I could also like not
take the biohazard card mmm take that
okay you should be planning's the name
of the game dude planning cleaning is my
middle name
I couldn't believe how evil he sounded
I've heard some evil people in my day
but he sounded like borderline I don't
know he was like a nutcase yeah well
well well God what the [ __ ] is that
[ __ ] hose then oh my god
hose it what is that Oh
are using the submachine guns don't use
those well oh no no you're right yeah
yeah sorry those are different ones
first of all the other ones aren't
loaded I don't think this is working
[ __ ] you use your green herb oh I'm
gonna die here's my head use your green
herb
nope never mind don't use it okay just
[ __ ] wait I'm only on four percent
down but yeah kill him kill him a lot
uh-huh and get ready to pull your
handgun
[ __ ] I can't believe he hit me use your
green turban okay listen I'm not doing
so great
it's good sweet and then like how is he
like turning around when I'm turning
around [ __ ] like I can't not get hit
here concentric circles Oh hard I I felt
like I got hit every time he attacked me
like there was no time where I was like
cool we were fine
no like I got hurt and everyone's not
automatic I don't think so
you yelled at me about that before
though yeah but in this situation like
to prevent him from hitting you I would
just say this is right right
yeah I just like don't know how to do
this better
I hadn't learn anything go full auto on
him he's done it a little bit more
all right we have to hear this again
actually a touchpad I did it okay all
right
stupid arm like the only time I could
avoid it was when I was like at the very
corner of the area and then he would
just walk forward a little bit and then
hit me next time I just I don't feel
like I know how to beat this thing
shoot him a lot more okay I like a full
auto and then lay your handgun out you
just hold that button down for that
right yeah and then I don't feel like so
did he walk up he's very good looking
nice
well let's guess they up here go pull on
it hold it oh right it doesn't wear it
what go down go back man thank you
not yet but like I didn't do very good
you know any man I'm not doing so hot I
should've brought the spray no you're
fine
nice is he hurt
oh good nice hey you fine yes [ __ ] you
he's breathing only works out one side
of his body he's like the dude from lady
in the world I remember that movie I
have seen it what a fantastic film
perfect in every way
yes I'm night shell on Milan
[Music]
God that movie sucked
alright so am I going this way wait it
ways that submachine gun ammo in here or
through that door I don't it must have
been through this door but I can't get
through it yeah yeah well you can't get
through the door I can't it's open you
just eat yeah like it's open already
just no - you're right it's already open
I'm dumb it's me oh [ __ ] Steve dune
act like I'm gonna save you all the time
wait is he looking at me and shooting
yeah oh yeah we need those golden
Lugar's for that thing I miss gonna
replace all
I was pretty cool there's Rick Moranis
don't worry Claire your knight in
shining armor is here oh just kill me
[Music]
you wish but thanks for the help
see this is why you need me I got your
back
whatever here take these
have some of the-- you know in exchange
for your Lugar's big dum-dum he like
literally just saved my life also he was
just gonna fire those guns in the wall
just found out there's no you always
test your guns at a wall lose some
weight way don't you oh I knew that was
[Music]
sweet they'll be good for viola guns
no there's no metaphor that you're just
gonna die oh this is stressful I have no
health and I don't want to do this man
let's do it
wait here Claire he's like pointing with
guns like is he dumb like don't do that
Oh Lord oh wait you're see I'm [ __ ]
Steve yeah shut up
these are Auto Oh [ __ ] always dead see
you losers
sashka no kill them oh it's me Steve
I'm back actually you could check your
inventory I'm sorry
oh listen thirty-four for a second damn
it son chewing on me the door right
there
there was a door where I came from -
though it's a good idea
yeah there's rumors we have a lot of
lights on us for this
is he coming back or like how are we
doing but
you're what wait why am i doing that
that hurt me that gas or probably what
am i doing honest oh [ __ ]
like I don't know what my goal is right
now it's kind of like walking testing
out your guns kill everybody I guess do
you like these guns hey Claire I manage
it should be safe now there well what do
you think of my work you see this thing
is a lot more reliable than any person
then people
that's good he's thinking about it
Steve what were you doing here I hate my
dad's Point Break the writer of this
game not a [ __ ] Nobel Prize shut up
II don't want to talk about it
oh my god I was playing guns are way
better than people
[Laughter]
oh yeah the other side of that this
isn't the same thing as my card is that
I need indigo card that makes sense so
where am i cool Oh an interesting
speaking Thai you're Azam
[Music]
are you okay Steve behind you oh it's my
dad no dad
what if it is his dad I'm sorry
do something Claire Jesus
[Music]
unloads two is ease into his undead dad
he's like on top of me putting very much
my body at risk no one told me and
father
Hideo Kojima wrote this game Briella
please turn it out information intended
to sell it off to the highest bidder
he was caught this is surreal mom was
killed we were sent here
[Music]
Oh Steve he was a fool to do something
so reckless so stupid
it's okay man just rats close-up of
zombie face zombie dad oh my god she's
in a fetal position now that was the
best thing that I've seen in this game
I'm very impressed with that entire
thing I was like super ambitious what
not the right word yeah like they were
like someone who sold that story was
like so you're gonna meet Steve and he's
gonna be like obviously obviously super
dad all right so that was weird
um what do I have
I'm on caution I got these golden losses
where did I come from do you remember
I'm actually not sure like what's that
what's this what are all these places Oh
[Music]
run [ __ ] am I going what's this one I
was gonna bring you back way back to the
beginning I think
oh my god turn around turn around go
back in there
go back Oh God let me go back yeah so
there might be something on the other
side of tank just keep dodging the dogs
though where am I going towards her this
way there's something on the ground near
those boxes here
yeah keep just look around near the
boxes yeah that's it oh [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] arrows yeah take them now you
can cut back to the saber that door get
away from me what am I going he'll I
gonna die I don't have any eels
hey good it's worth it yeah circle
around go is that single door [ __ ] ass
dog here yeah
now get ready does the worm where am I
going back in the original doors or back
into the left like that way the door
that I tried to get to know oh yeah that
one that's the window
oh my god I'm sorry that one okay
now you're back here should really use
that am i doing like all right where am
I going
can you go through there this one yeah
don't look through there yet though
go into the room is this the storage
door this is the bath yes but I don't
have a key if I have the key I can do it
you're a hottie and arrows where's this
storage door I think it's like here
it's like this okay I think the safest
clothes closest save room is the palace
do we not have a save oh wait no you're
right um yeah okay the shutter you just
opened you can go down that way and
that's back into the area where Alfred
attacked you which is right near a safe
room so unless it's locked down I don't
think where am I going through that
shutter here you know the shredder to
the right I said shredder not to peek up
I said shutter half this is a door I
can't understand you
[Music]
it was scary actually you kind of sound
like him yeah you know I'm a voyeur
voice-acted in my life okay so this is
where Alfred ambushed you
I really hope I didn't lead you into an
ambush and I go with that one
the less mm yeah okay this is where
Alfred ran hopefully don't run again
each sniper rifle you in the face that's
not how snipers are meant to be you know
yeah say brew sweet mm-hmm storage key
you can use that and now you have the
golden mover you go back to Palace
anyway I don't think you want to save it
I would healed in here though sure or at
least bring a healing item okay all
right
okay so let's talk about this get ready
goddamn arrows
I have 210 arrows that I cannot use
bring I don't need these anymore I don't
need the golden Lugar's or now cuz
you're gonna you have to go back to the
palace anyway for those and there's a
saver in there are you sure yes well my
inventory
just like hella opened up green herb is
that enough you think yeah I'll feel bad
if I die though Oh what
[Music]
okay yeah so that shutter didn't close
behind you this time so you should be
good going back down so I think so okay
I got to watch out for the dog so yeah
that's my biggest concern
do you think the dogs are upstairs I
hate these goddamn dogs go away did I
get the key
all right so hole this didn't close
behind you keep going yeah let's get
whatever is in here I hope it's a
[ __ ] arrow gun that would be cool
wouldn't it cuz I have all these stupid
arrows easy stupid
[Music]
yes what is that explosive arrows or
something
check that desk over there
[Music]
so I risk my life for for some boat
powder Lord alright back to the mansion
right Monty Oum I think there's some
stuff you wouldn't do and but I have the
golden Luke's yeah be a good time to
call the episode once you get there
anyway just dodged the worm poke ended
with the worm log no weird hate that
worm your worms
please don't come out please don't come
out but you're fine
we caught these barriers are all
accessible do you think the lugs um open
up like a new area oh my [ __ ] god
yeah gap it's - oh my god there's two of
those things
it's a saver are you [ __ ] kidding me
are you kidding two of them also suck
sake I cleared this place
it kills someone I'd well yep once you
find a bug on your some ammo to use
[Music]
yeah all right I'm [ __ ] sick of this
[ __ ]
nice
there's a major thing I'm trying not to
spoil throughout the entire game I'm
trying to subtly lead you toward things
so at the same time I also don't
remember a lot of it so I don't know
whether you should trust me or not sweet
um so I'm getting the golden Luke's time
is it my bigoted time is save okay we
aren't they in this room oh they're
downstairs I think oh you're totally
right there yeah you might as well get
that sweet like the only thing that
would be bad about this is if it like
starts a chain reaction that I can't
stop I think you'll be fine
[Music]
some nice Luke's he looked at the
shooting range logo from mom I mean what
do you think
can i peep in there or do I get like
I've no I don't remember all right how
about this let's save and then I'm gonna
totally look in there real fast that way
if it is like another worm I don't lose
a lot of progress okay I actually do not
have a lot of pucks
I might even notices like maybe I
shouldn't have used that puck halfway
through but I died so it's good I use
the puck oh yeah wait what no no you're
fine
I just wait what do you mean you died
it's good so I'm what I'm saying is is
like you only have so many memory slots
and so yeah and I used one halfway
through this episode which I shouldn't
typically do but I died halfway through
right after using it actually so I'm
like glad I used it because I could have
like been screwed
oh yeah the loup-garou
handgun rounds sweet oh this room sweet
that sucks well I'm gonna to do this all
again so let's see what it is you are
quite good at turning me on Alfred
whatever that god she's such a creep
love you
pathless go check what that blue glowing
thing was
or we can wait until next time or
there's something on the desk too
okay there's a lot going on here and I
don't think you yeah I'm trying to get
out I just missed something earlier that
you need but it's not a big deal
well there was something nagging and you
know okay all right we'll deal with this
next time yeah I think you're doing well
for this game yeah nervous but well
gunpowder which I'm pretty sure just
combines to make explosive arrows hell
it's pretty good fainting is really
weird up there there's a lot of weird
stuff going on left right left
all right cool like we're getting we're
getting into it now oh sweet tomorrow's
April Fool's
once this publishes Sunday oh yeah
anyway happy April Fool's yeah that's my
niece's birthday it's not an April
Fool's she's actually her birthday I
feel that's unfortunate I know but she's
really cool happy birthday Sarah
but anyway he has a heart no let's see
yeah see you next week thanks for
watching Knievel thanks for joining us
don't forget to Like and subscribe it
helps GameSpot do more stuff like this
say hi to us on Twitter but bye
that's pretty good episode I did good
yeah I didn't die